hey you guys it's Friday again and it
that means it's time for another movie
retrospective and now we're finally
finally getting around doing this it's
just funny because this is like such an
iconic like a classic and everything and
it's like we did Blade Runner 2049 first
which I guess is a little weird but we
always knew that eventually we were
gonna get around to doing the original
classic now before we get too much into
this we should say as you all know if
you're fans of the original Blade Runner
there are like seven or eight different
versions of this ship floating her hub
and Jenny got me a copy of the final cut
on blu-ray yeah a couple months back and
boy it took us a long time to even get
around to watch it I know we have well
we have so many movies and it's like now
we have shudder we have Netflix we have
you know we watch stuff on to be and
[ __ ] like that so it's like we just you
know and I you know and I have a lot of
work to do too so I don't have time to
just like sit around watching stuff but
we've finally finally got around yeah
first up like to say that on blu-ray
Blade Runner looks fantastic it looks
better on blu-ray than it's ever looked
like if you ever saw this on VHS oh you
know with the old CRT televisions yeah
you know what you're missing I mean this
thing it looks really really good it has
held up over the years in terms of just
you know the way things are shot and the
matte paintings and the models and yeah
it looks good it still amazes me that
this movie looks the way it looks from
1982 and like I said all you kids out
there no CGI didn't have CTA 1982 all of
that is models set design matte
paintings yeah all of that and actually
a lot of the buildings that are in there
are actually real buildings that were in
LA and stuff like that but the the city
streets that's actually a back lot it's
you it's the back lot that's usually
used for New York City like in some
movies when they shoot it on a back lot
but it's just set dressed so and it's
amazing to me that that looks like I
mean I like in in the sense that it
looks kind of like a set because you get
this like claustrophobic like it's LA
it's like I guess the implication being
that the pollution is so bad that like
the Sun never comes out so it's like
always nighttime it's always raining
what could get kind of orange yeah and
so it's just like this dark oppressive
and honestly when this movie came out I
mean it got mixed reviews at the time
like everyone was time it was visually
stunning there was really nothing like
this you know but some people were like
oh they didn't really know what was
going on like I said you know a lot of
the reviews from 1982 came from the
theatrical cut which famously had the
voiceover which Harrison Ford hated and
didn't want to do that was like a studio
I grew up with it I actually liked the
voice-over voice I'm just used to it
yeah like I know that it gave it more of
a film noir kind of feeling because that
you know that was something that film or
I usually had that the hard-boiled
detective like given the you know this
is how at the beginning but like I said
Harrison Ford really really really did
not want to do it it was done later on
after you know the studio was afraid
that test audiences they oh they won't
know what's going on and yeah I think I
think they were I think they were
correct about that because the
voice-over actually helped us along
through the movie yes but if you were
younger you know during this time when
this movie came out the science the
modern science fiction genre you know
from aliens and you know it was new yeah
so it helped describe the setting of the
way the planet was yeah true you know I
think it's I guess sci-fi wasn't new as
a genre but it was I think the 70s were
the first time that sci-fi had been
taken series right it was realistic and
was at least in movies I mean it had
been in books for many you know decades
before that but it does seem like it was
the first time that it was taken
seriously and and used as like a
commentary on the present day like you
know socio-political yes and the fans
were different back then
you know I remember it I saw this in
theatres I'll tell you story about I saw
this in theatres in those days science
fiction fans were young the older
generations didn't give a [ __ ] about
science fiction yeah you know when you
went there you know the the the the
theater was pretty much empty just
teenagers well it's like horror yeah
like a skewed younger so you know having
the voice-over helped teenagers actually
kind of get through the movie understand
what was going on this is kind of do
some deep [ __ ] yeah Blade Runner it's a
deep movie yeah it's a you know
futuristic world run by
corporations would and that sound
familiar run by corporations that kind
of your SERP to the government power and
in and in this story they're creating
basically they're creating slaves
they're taking genetically engineered
people and assembling them to skirt
slavery laws so you can keep your
civilization going yeah technically it's
not a person but it's a person in every
way except that ostensibly they don't
feel any empathy or they don't have any
feelings although they only give them a
four year lifespan because they're
afraid that they will develop emotions
and feelings if they do seem to do yeah
and I think that that's kind of like I
mean obviously everybody knows this is
based on a 1968 philip k dick novel do a
stream of blood which I read is nothing
like the movie it's really not a lot
like like the the kind of bare bones of
the story are similar but I feel like
one they don't use the word replicant in
the book it's Android or Andes they call
them also less the androids are less
sympathetic I feel like in the movie
theater Psychopaths yeah in the movie
Blade Runner because here's the thing
like philip k dick has came out and said
the androids in the book were actually
they were inspired by I mean the novel
did he'd written previous to this book
was a man in the high castle so for
doing research for that he had read like
a lot of Diaries of like high-ranking
Nazis and he's like so I used that as
like that was kind of a parallel to the
androids because he was like they seemed
human but they had no sympathy they had
no empathy for other people like and he
got that from like reading Nazi Diaries
so in the book the androids are not
really sympathetic characters so there
were a lot of screenplays written you
know for what would eventually become
Blade Runner interestingly the term
Blade Runner is also not in the book and
it came from a book I believe it was by
William s Burroughs like a novella and
he just liked the title of it so he said
can I just use that title it doesn't
have anything to do with what the
novella is about he's like I just like
that title and so he bought the rights
to
that time originally it was called
dangerous days I think and the
characters were all different - yeah
they in the book yeah yeah it was just a
different but yeah Roy was more like a
farmer type not really a Soren I think
Chris and Rachel were kind of merged
into just frist it was well word the
same model they looked exactly alike so
there was the whole thing about Deckard
falling in love with Rachel but then he
had to kill Priss still so it was like
kind of weird because they looked
exactly alike yeah and they also had
things like artificial insects and real
insects too you know it was pretty weird
yeah find an artificial horn toads out
in a desert yeah I mean it was a process
called Kipple yeah never careful did you
read the book a very okay a couple was
like something in this culture it's not
in the movie but it's in the book
debris things that break down and fall
up and turn into junk it becomes kibble
that's how I remembered it and that
Kipple was taking over the earth yeah
because it was just falling apart just
in crazy television shows but like I
said I liked it honestly I think the you
know philip k dick actually died shortly
before this movie came out he did
actually read a few iterations of the
script he didn't like most of them but
then you know the later one that David
people's mostly did he saw some of the
drawings and someone saw some of the
photographs like some of the you know
kind of special effects work and stuff
and he really really liked it like he
said that world that's exactly what I
pictured like when I read it but sadly
he did not get to see the finish maybe
he died actually quite young infinitely
53 I think he he was a substance abuser
tell you that guy and he was a little
bit crazy well yeah he was great well
most creative people right are a little
bit crazy otherwise their Total Recall
and you know a lot of his stuff is
turned in well and honestly I Blade
Runner was kind of the beginning of that
because even though I mean it went a
little bit over budget it went a little
bit over time you know but and it did
okay at the box office not great you
know you have to think it's the same
thing that happened with the thing you
know 1982 that was the same year
et came out that seemed your rock III
came out and those just like stomped all
over every other movie pretty much that
came
that year that summer so and Blade
Runner was a little cerebral I feel like
it did well like I said it did well
critically sort of half and half but
really it wasn't until a little bit
later that it got like a critical
reassessment an audience races and it
started like building up a cult classic
and honestly Blade Runner I feel like is
probably if not the most influential
science fiction movie pretty much ever
made I mean it took cues from you know
film noir it took cues from metropolis
you know from the 20s and stuff but I
feel like the look of Blade Runner every
single sci-fi movie that came after that
every video game that came after that I
mean that was kind of like the whole
cyberpunk think like game from that
pretty much yeah and I think I read this
might have been on the Wikipedia page
but they said that Blade Runner is
actually the music and the dialogue
format are the most sampled music and
dialogue from any movie of the 20th
century I remember when it was in the
theaters you know I was getting the
feedback I was getting from from people
at the time they thought they didn't
like it yeah and I was visiting my dad
in Mississippi at the time that this
came out and it was playing at the
sawmill Square Mall I was watching one
movie and I passed the theater yeah
where Blade Runner was was playing and I
just cracked open at the door and I
heard you know the sounds like you know
the audio of a fight scene or something
happens I walked in just in time to see
Daryl Hannah
turning turning Deckard's face around
right into her credit she was beating
him up and breaking his nose and stuff I
was like what the [ __ ] is this movie
about god damn so uh week after that you
know I I went to go see it was r-rated
and III wasn't old enough to see an
r-rated movie so I got a ticket for one
movie and then went in to that one to go
see it like we that's how we used to
play we just made it look like we were
following the rules so I snuck into
their watch it was pretty good I liked
it yeah although I was very disoriented
at the time oh you don't mean like wow
what kind of movie is this and I didn't
know anything about directors that
know that you know Ridley Scott you know
or you know was involved in this I
didn't make the connection that this was
the same universe that alien one was
from and and I don't think alien two had
come out yet no so this was this movie
after a right right so it was pretty
cool you know and it continues on into
Prometheus and into alien covenant and
you know when you get into those movies
that makes Blade Runner make a lot more
sense yeah that they have all these you
know basically huge tycoons and robber
barons and and big corporations trying
to build slave races of androids and
replicates you know to expand human
conquest of the universe they're making
new colonies on other planets and you
know when they said to offworld colonies
in in Blade Runner at that time I was
thinking what Mars yeah that's what I
was thinking I didn't realize that they
were going to other solar systems right
yeah I didn't realize they had that
technology although it did it was
inferred you know said several times in
in Blade Runner that if you couldn't
pass certain physicals you had to stay
on earth yeah and that everybody else
was leaving yeah that seemed like and
that seemed like where the germ of the
idea for Gattaca came from yes Earth was
a [ __ ] country basically well that's and
the thing about Blade Runner too and
there's kind of things about they
actually initially didn't want Harrison
Ford to be in it but not they didn't
want him but he wasn't like their first
choice when the script was written they
actually wanted Robert Mitchum because
the whole neo-noir thing then they
wanted Dustin Hoffman but Dustin Hoffman
is like that's not the kind of character
I usually play no thank you
so then finally they got Harrison Ford
to do it now Harrison Ford and Ridley
Scott um you know they made up later on
but there was a very famously
contentious relationship between the two
of them now Ridley Scott has gone on
record and I'm sorry this is a spoiler
alert for you guys but he is gone on
record as saying yes Deckard was a
replicant and if you watch the two write
the final director's cut which is the
one that I bought you that's on blu-ray
the the scene where he said we're deck
has the unicorn dream and then there's
the origami unicorn that at the end that
gaff leaves and everything and that's
you know meant to say you know I know
what you're thinking because our
memories are implanted so Ridley Scott I
said yes Deckard is a replicant now
Harrison Ford was like [ __ ] that I'm not
a replicant and then he was like I
didn't play it like that but the
interesting thing is that even though he
didn't play it like that the interesting
thing to me in this movie is that the
replicants seem more human than the
humans and they even like to kind of say
that that's like Tyrrells whole thing
it's like more human than human but it
actually does end up being true because
even though the replicants are kind of I
mean they do like sociopathic
sociopathic things but the humans in
this story are also very emotionally
dead inside everyone seems to live by
themselves everywhere very lonely and
particularly Deckard's character seems
very detached and so it's kind of an
interesting and even like the end where
Roy batty like before he dies that he
actually saves Harrison Ford's life even
though he didn't have to he could have
just like Lennon so it was almost like
he was a better person like a more moral
person than Deckard was yeah well you
know in Blade 1 or 2049 you know the the
guy that's making replicant is basically
calling them his angels yeah and this
kind of ties in with stuff that happened
in Prometheus and about human corruption
if you look at Blade Runner 2049 and
they'll whole expanded universe humans
are bad yeah that's you know and one of
the reasons why they're making these
replicants in these androids is because
they're better than humans yeah that's
what their interview no they're right
the guys that are making them are trying
to make better replacements for humans
that humans aren't very good yeah
and they kind of show you know a lot of
scenes in Blade Runner 20:49 of how
humans how real humans act and they're
[ __ ] yeah a lot of corruption in
them you know so so like I said that was
something that was Scott's vision
because that wasn't really in the
original book where he's kind of making
the implication and this was a little
bit clearer I think in the director's
cut because I mean like I said the us
the theatrical cut in that that had like
the happy ending and all that that crap
but like you know the the later one that
was restored that's actually closest to
Scott's vision it does seem to make a
lot clearer that the replicants are more
sympathetic than any of the human than
any of the humans in this story I mean
you feel bad for them they escaped from
slavery and they and you know Roy bad
even says to Deckard's character you
know he's like I want you to feel fear
like we feel he wants him to empathize
with him but Decker doesn't really seem
to even though he does eventually you
know fall in love with Rachel and
everything like that and you know so he
kind of redeems us off the end but I
think that's kind of like the whole
really the whole kind of theme of all of
those moves like Prometheus and all the
way up to present day is like you might
as well throw in soldier in there too
from Korea with Kurt Russell yeah
because across all across what is but
when Roy is dying he talks about that he
he mentions Tannhauser gate you know
yeah ships on fire and and Tannhauser
gate
Tannhauser gate was one of the tattoos
that crustle had on his arm from soldier
one of the battles that he fought in yes
so you can see so there there was the
cross over yeah I think well one of the
underlying themes of the whole universe
is really you know once you get to a
point of artificial intelligence where
you know maybe the the replicants are
better than human is there really any
difference and I think there was kind of
like this whole moral thing and Blade
Runner to of like Deckard almost coming
to the realization that he's like
they're the same as me
you know what I mean yeah but that's
like I said that's something that
underlies like what makes us human if
you have implanted like Rachel's
character for example you know she had
implanted memories that she thought were
real you know because she thought she
was a person she shows Deckard the
picture she's like look this is me when
I was little and he's like yeah no
that's that's Tyrells niece you know
they implanted all those memories and
all the same well the Nexus 6 and you
can also connect this in with David from
Prometheus and right alien covenant
David was supposed to be an improved
human yes supposed to be better than
human but in the end he ended up doing
evil stuff too and he's develop hatred
so it's just I don't know are they
better maybe not are you know are we
better than them are they better than us
it's I think I think part of the message
there is just consciousness has certain
emergent properties to it that exactly
when you're dealing with reality you
start to become corrupt yeah that's what
they're what they're talking about yeah
and I think the interesting thing too is
that you know the more human that they
get the more flawed that they ride so
like I said you know there is no
difference in the end right if you can
make something to that you know that
proximity to a human being then there is
no difference yeah it's kind of like you
know the lot you're thinking when you're
a child it's very different from when
you're an adult when you're a child you
kind of believe in things not a man you
can't tend to be kind of you know they
call it innocent you know but when you
get older you start to become kind of
corrupt in a certain way you know and
that's what they're talking about
some people get corrupted at earlier
ages yeah it's like you said it's it's
an occupational hazard yeah exactly and
so like I said you know the closer and I
think that's kind of the point that
reality's a little too complicated right
you know that's the point that he's
trying to make is that it is that you're
doomed to failure if you you the closer
you try to make these robots essentially
that you know the more human you try to
make them more like what they are
drastically wrong did you know that
Daryl Hannah was actually I know this is
kind of like out of left field but did
you know that Daryl Hannah was actually
not the first choice to play press do
you know who was new Debbie Harry okay
yeah I can see that they actually wanted
Debbie Harry and Debbie Harry actually
kind of wanted to do it but her record
company said now that's gonna take too
much time out of your music career so
you better not and she later on said
that she regretted oh yeah she should
the scene she actually would have been
really good that movie made Daryl
Hannah's career I did yeah
and had had event Debbie Harry she
probably would have been in more movies
than in better movies yeah well she was
in all this she wasn't she was in a lot
yes she was but she would've been in
more I think yeah probably but you know
like I said this this what can you say
about this movie that hasn't already
been said like a million times it's like
this is like I said easily easily if you
haven't seen it you have to see it one
of the most if not the most influential
I mean [ __ ] look at all the [ __ ]
video games that came from look at all
the sci-fi that came after look at all
the fiction that came after all the
knockoffs like transfers because you had
kind of hyped it to me yeah I remember
liking it a lot then we got and I'm like
memory wasn't that good about it well
back in those days you know my buddies
were watching we're probably talking
through most of it anyway
yeah so you use just like every now and
then yeah I don't know it's a different
time doesn't happen quite as much um
honestly I have to say a lot of movies
that I liked back in the 80s and then I
watch them again usually I'm like oh
that's better than I remembered every
now and then I'll see you I don't notice
what Ranchers the first 15 10 or 15
minutes was interesting and then it just
started to fall apart
yeah continued to fall apart and it just
kept falling apart yeah I was like when
it first came on I'm like well it looks
kind of cheap but then yeah you know
that's not a deal breaker I'm alright
yeah it's like then I was watching and
I'm like it got worse and worse and
worse can you understand it you lied to
me
but yeah so and they made like four or
five of those things I wouldn't think it
was kind of like maybe they get better I
and I'm not gonna like take time out
there's a lot of good movies out the one
the ones the one that I really am mad
that I missed back in the day was
phantasm as it was coming out I wish I
had seen it because that was actually a
really good series that got better as it
went I didn't see the first yeah I saw
the second one when it came out cuz I
saw it in the theater
and then I went back and watched the
first one because I had missed the first
one also yeah but I did see the second
one in the theater when it came in every
day that's a good series
I know and it's like it's weird because
I saw that but then like I never saw
like three four and five or anything
like that but that was one of the few
series that got better as it went yeah
yeah ever happens the last one was
awesome it became like you know it's
like Mad Max at the end of the world
yeah like I said there's a lot you can
do with that yeah and you know getting
back to Blade Runner that's kind of like
why you know I think that's why that
movie has stood the test of time one
because it looks amazing and like I said
it just pro tip if you're ever gonna
make a sci-fi movie or you know write
sci-fi it's more movie than book I guess
a book you can get away a lot more but
if you don't want your sci-fi to age one
don't you CGI one - don't make don't try
to make it like futuristic it's better
to like go back to the past it's better
to make things look used get your used
future things that's why Star Wars still
works you know the original Star Wars
trilogy that's why Blade Runner still
works because they went back to the 40s
they went back to they didn't try to
make everybody like oh let's put like
these big pointy like yeah shiny
everything looks brand-new you know
right all the war machines are you have
a fresh coat of paint on them and sure
no no no you want chipped paint you want
rust what oil smudges on things you want
it to be rain wet everywhere you know
yeah where reality really looks right
and the thing about Blade Runner too is
that you know everybody like a lot of
people were poor so you'd be using like
old [ __ ] you know what I mean and the
same thing with the original Star Wars
trilogy it's like you know oh well we
live on this like backwater planet and
it's like so we have to get like all
these [ __ ] junk [ __ ] from yeah the
intergalactic version of Goodwyn it
looked like everything was modified and
upgraded like an old cars with new stuff
stuck on it to keep it relevant yeah
yeah so I you know I think that's why
you know sci-fi movies like that have
just because you don't try to like me
because there's so many sci-fi movies
that came out in the 80s that we're
trying to like eat this Total Recall
suffered from this a little bit to where
it's like let's make everything look
super futuristic but then when you watch
it now you're like wow that is so yeah
because everyone's hair and like it just
so just go back to some iconic yeah
period sure you'd be doing a movie and I
think like I said Blade Runner since it
went back to the 40s like everyone just
looked like it's like femme fatale
hard-boiled detective tell you what
though one of the futuristic movies that
did that did stand the test of time and
still looks good to this day his
demolition man the vehicles really do
look like cars of today got the cars
they've got a lot of stuff correct on
although in twenty thirty years it might
look dated I don't know yeah today I see
I would never like you know if anybody
ever asked me the math shots look really
good it's just the concept cars that
that blue foam into the cabin to keep
you from getting crushed you know and
during the impact it just got a lot of
stuff right in that what was it
teleconferencing yeah
social credit score they have all that
yeah so it's like I said it's if I
wouldn't probably never do as I find
just cuz like I said I'm more like an
old-school horror person but if anybody
ever asked me to make a sci-fi movie I
would definitely go the route of you
know using some iconic period in history
rather than trying to make everything
look futuristic you know what I mean or
just make everything look functional
like don't try to make cuz I like I said
I think a little bit Back to the Future
kind of the second one kind of fell into
that to where it's like everything was
super eighties
yeah take whatever's popular now make it
extreme yeah and it's like that's not
the future works no the future does not
work like that I mean it's it's cyclical
I think people think of it as like a
progressive dead giveaway is that you
know we made we were making that stuff
in the late 80s and they just didn't
foresee the internet or the the impact
of the Internet
hardly anyone know that's really crazy
oh so what they had that terrible
looking 3d holograms
yeah and fax machines all in the house
remember that that was him lots of
televisions that will come out of the
ceiling and that's not the way the
future was fax machines of death instead
of internet they just had they could
just show more cable television's that
want more cable channel you know well I
guess that all that wrong reason reason
Blade Runner works is because they
didn't do any of that generally I mean
they they kind of you get focused more
on the care
focus more on you know they had Androids
that's still way ahead you know way in
the future probably at least ones that
look exactly like humans but well the
replicants weren't Androids reps were
more like Frankenstein's you make a
bunch of a bunch of internal organs you
grow them and then you assemble it and
bring the things back to life anything
to life and give it memories it doesn't
know what it is yeah the androids they
had those but you don't see those until
alien one yeah I mean with what was what
was that character's name oh yeah
crap yeah the one that tried to shove
that rolled up Misha Bishop I know
Bishop was the second was the other one
yeah he took that rolled-up magazine
tried to stuff it down yeah down
ripley's throat yeah but date when they
saw that that was a robot you know they
were surprised that it was a robot so I
don't think that they were very common
yeah true you know I do I feel like the
whole and I think there's kind of an
underlying thing to of like the Tyrell
corporation hmm because in Blade Runner
you know you're thinking oh well they're
just making replicants like his slave
labor essentially but I think as the
series went on it kind of got more to
the thing where they just wanted to
replace humans altogether yeah yeah they
wanted anyone to get rid of humans yeah
humans wouldn't obey right yeah you know
now I'm trying to sort it out in the
timeline accorded through Prometheus and
everything I guess in the Blade Runner
time there would have been primitive
androids that were robots Sebastian had
things that look like they may have been
androids the little we built those yeah
right right so they were his friends
yeah so he knew about genetic design and
in and robotics yeah it's kind of doing
both but look like the genetic stuff was
moving along more quickly than the
robotics at that time yeah which is
funny because the original Blade Runner
is supposed to be set in 2019 which is
only a few months away now yeah like a
month away which is pretty weird yeah
and we have a lot of better technology
than they yeah in terms of computer
technology yeah
there was no way that they would have
known and this is this is an alternate
future anyway and it doesn't really
stand out to me much in Blade Runner
because like I said it's not all
whiz-bang like ooh there's big computers
everywhere and stuff like that it's like
yeah people have like computer monitors
various things and they look old and
clunky but it's like the whole place
looks poor yeah gross and eat up and in
in the book which is the source material
the the world was falling apart and it
was all made out of junk anyway that's
what I'm so you know the Blade Runner
world or 2019 would have had CRT
televisions and that was thrown together
just out of old junk yeah would have
just picked it out of a garbage because
they couldn't afford to buy you just
remade it into something else yes so
that's kind of a it's bother me like I
said and it's you know that's why that's
why it's aged so well is because it had
that whole used future thing they didn't
try to make it look like super
futuristic or anything like that so you
know like I said I think that's one
Detroit yeah even though like I said
most of the outside was LA but it was
just that dressed and and interesting
thing too because like I said back in
the days poor CGI some of those shots
what they would do is they would film
the street or whatever then they would
back the film up change the lighting and
then film it again and like they would
layer it like over top of each other you
know what I mean so they could get like
different like weird lighting effects
and like your darks that's how they used
to do it it's like now it's now it's
super easy to learn earlier stuff or you
know and you can do it digitally but
back then they had Blake crank the thing
back and film it back over again if I'll
be back over again with like different
lighting effects and stuff and then you
just have friends of ours friends of
ours just watch to this movie for the
first time I think they saw the final
cut they hadn't seen the other cuts and
you know they were young they'd never
seen the movie before and they just they
were like what did that what was that
movie about it didn't you know they
didn't really get it yeah they didn't
understand the importance of it either I
think it's you know young people today
are just they're not impressed by any
kind of imagery because they grew up
seeing you know fantastic imagery yeah
you're gonna burst and yeah it's hard to
go that in they didn't couldn't really
understand why it was an important movie
it's hard to go back to that well
because and I think this happens with a
lot of kind of yog Rafi it's not their
fault it's we were born after wrong but
a lot of times
you're younger you'll see stuff that
came out you know during your formative
years and then when you go back and see
the things that inspired that thing that
you saw you'd be like yeah big whoop I
saw this right was better but you didn't
understand it like being about 80 to
nothing looked like Blade Runner right
it's like now that movie was so
influential that it's easy to just look
back and get it at that good yeah big
deal I've seen Dark City I've seen Total
Recall I've seen all this other [ __ ]
but without realizing it was actually
inspired by that so there was a Sean
Connery movie that came out I think
before this or maybe it's a little bit
after might have been before it's called
out land I remember that man I haven't
seen that a long time either about a cop
on the moon aisle they were mining
something he was trying to stop this
drug that was coming there and people go
crazy now we're gonna have to like get
that that one that one didn't hold up
too well I don't know watch it I'm like
what the hell question I didn't taste
that one probably didn't hold up too
well what well because I feel like cuz I
saw like a [ __ ] ton of movies when I was
younger like in the late 70s and early
80s and I figure like if it was super
good then I still remember it I remember
there was a time where I thought out
land and Blade Runner were about at the
same level but I guarantee you out land
is nothing is cool yeah because if it
was as good as Blade Runner everybody
like I remember seeing it but it didn't
make it although the 2010 held up pretty
well although I much prefer 2001 I have
to say I mean 2003 good yeah it was good
but it was more it was more of a kind of
standard yeah yeah structure which you
know I I'm not so into that it's kind of
standards high-end 80s yeah yeah that's
what I mean it was a lot more
conventional right and you know weight
was made I mean yeah I'm kind of more
like I like experience it was a movie
for the masses exactly and that's
probably why I didn't like it as good
alright so anyway we've waffled on and
on about the original Blade Runner like
I said jeez I'm sure we just we just had
to add our yeah it's more like
commentary because if you haven't seen
this man you get
get out of here you haven't seen this we
we say that about a lot of movies who do
this really evil does it like that
really like yeah but yeah so if you
haven't seen it and I'm sure most of you
have seen it if you haven't seen Blade
Runner 2049 we have oh yeah you also did
a review of that and that was it a like
also an amazing
20:49 III adventure the same it's
probably a better movie um it's not as
earth-shattering right true not as
groundbreaking but 2049 the way that
that thing looks and what happens in the
movie in the scope of that it's a lot
more it's a lot better
I've watched that movie like so many
times and it's just you top there like
sit there and legs up there with fury
road different kind of movie but in in
epicness it's up there yeah hopefully
they do a really good job on the new
dude on the new doom yeah cuz the same
dude who did 20 49 s gonna do yes
I hope that they'd have a Dino De
Laurentiis style dune with those
uniforms and that that look man I love
that look you have to make that like
super epic yeah you have to go big or go
home like I said you can't just do that
I'm ready you get the [ __ ] out here
right because there's so many bad TV
series versions of the [ __ ] dude it's
just it's crazy to me the way it's like
if you don't have like zillions of
dollars to make that just don't bother
let me have I have yet to have unlimited
resources and super super good CG cuz I
feel like I I feel like this is kind of
true of any movie if you only have like
say a million dollars to make a movie
make a [ __ ] ghost story set in one
where you don't try to make some big
epic like sprawling sci-fi those like on
five planets and [ __ ] like then you're
gonna work out in that Dino De
Laurentiis dune those sets and those
costumes make that movie ya know that
I've seen so many different edits of it
the short theatrical edit actually is
the way to go because the more you see
that movie the more [ __ ] up it is yeah
man
most of that movie is terrible
you have to just edit it down just to
that theatrical release or it's just the
extended television release version of
that you can you can see that is just a
sea that was [ __ ] one I saw initially I
didn't get the atra Kolkata Sarang Vica
which is like way long
yeah TV cuts almost like and I'm like I
can't even sit through it's like and I'm
not dumb like I can follow stories and I
have read the book and stuff like that
so it's like yes and a lot of the acting
is really bad with the added acting that
they cut yeah but it's not a movie of a
movie at least it wasn't then not a
moveable book yeah they say that about a
lot of stuff though and then sometimes
they make my death later it's like China
make a movie out of the Old Testament I
mean there's just too much material
there and a lot of it's contradictory is
it because it was written it like
different times by different people and
it's just kind of like a hodgepodge and
something awful together but you know
this and the thing about Blade Runner
too like you know getting back to Blade
Runner it's like because there are so
many different cuts of it I mean if the
only thing you've seen is the US
theatrical cut with the happy ending and
the voice-over and everything like that
I think you should probably see the
director's cut because it's kind of it's
called the final cut yeah it's called
the final cut yeah the director's cut is
a different to different that was done
like under his supervision but he didn't
have finals yeah you're good didn't get
the final cut on blu-ray it looks
fantastic yeah and I actually like it
better it has a more ambiguous and it's
a different experience yeah and the tone
of it it fits in with a lot better with
Blade Runner 2049 yeah so there's
continuity there in the tone cuz I think
that's kind of the definitive version
because that's the one that Ridley Scott
said this is the this is how I wanted it
to be yeah even though I gotta tell you
there's some missing scenes deleted
scenes some of them still exist so you
can find them on YouTube but there was
some stuff that was never shot
originally Roy was supposed to kill
tyrell and then find a heat secret
elevator that took him all the way down
underneath that pyramid to where he
found the real tyrell instead right yeah
and then he talked to him yeah right in
the same way that you could talk to
somebody while they were in hypersleep
in what you call it
Prometheus yeah yeah right yeah but yeah
so that was one of the reason why Ford
didn't like the movie because some of
the some of the best stuff about the
movie was left out left out
well can I that like you said they
didn't shoot that that was in the
original they had drawings of it though
yeah yeah drawings in the head of part
of the school they had it blocked out in
the subscript of what was gonna be said
and you were gonna find out a lot more
about Tyrell in these replicants yeah
but it like I said I think Scott liked
to leak kind of leave it ambiguous and
he liked it better that it was left
ambiguous so that's why I was kind of
like that and like I said you know the
final cut is probably the one I'd
recommend cuz that was the one that was
closest to what he wanted and it ties in
better with 2049 like you said if you
have a double feature one night right
I've set aside three or five six hours
six hours and watch both of them just
you know it'll be it'll be fantastic
alright so that'll do it for our latest
movie review remember if you like the
show to like share subscribe with all
your social media and with all your
friends and family
also if you'd like to financially
support the show you can go to our
patreon page which is patreon.com slash
13 o'clock podcast or you can go to our
blog which is 13 o'clock podcast
wordpress.com and there's a link in the
sidebar to a PayPal account remember
that our movie reviews come out every
Friday we also have matinee which is new
movies in the theater that comes out
every Sunday and we also have our
regular episodes of course which come
out every Tuesday so check those out if
you haven't already and until next time
bye